if Wizards forced you to secretly join a
magic school to save your family what
would you do you'll have to be at the
world's best magic users in order to
climb up the ranks and become the
school's Divine Visionary I'm going to
break down the mistakes made what you
should do and how to beat the Eastern
magic Academy in Marshall magic and
muscles this freak of nature will be
forced to go undercover and battle
terrifying Wizards in a world ruled by
magical users smash here is different
born with no power no magic and a little
bit dumb he's grown up in a forest with
his dad and has been forced to train and
prepare for when the world finally finds
out about his terrifying secret one day
Mash's dad regrow steps out of the house
and warns Mash not to go into town under
any circumstances and mash listens to
him but as soon as he gets hungry he
conveniently forgets about his dad's
orders and heads into town for lunch a
town that he's never been to before and
as he walks through town nothing happens
everything's fine until he tries to
order some food and that's when people
start to notice his unmarked face
everybody knows who he is he's something
rare a non-magic user and he continues
to gather attention and that's when he
bumps into this police officer and he's
drunk on the job this officer creates a
mess and mash accidentally rips his
shirt off causing even more trouble and
that's when another officer arrives a
superior named Brad and he's the police
chief he looks at Mash dead in the face
and realizes what he's looking at but
just then Augusta wind blasts right past
them and mash is taken away by his dad
but oh it's too late realizing that the
kid is a freak Brad sends a magical bird
to track them down deep into the forest
as mash and his dad Retreat back into
the woods and once they get back home
the dad is furious at Mash but then he
remembers that his son is not exactly
the brightest tool in the shed and
quickly forgives him and that's when
mash then hands him some cream puffs oh
that's nice and he goes out to train
again for the fourth time today as
punishment and that's when the magical
police bust down the door and get into
the house holding Mash's dad hostage
they demand to know where the non-magic
user is and cue ball daddy keeps his
mouth shut forcing the police to do what
they do best commit magical police
brutality meanwhile Mash finishes his
workout in five minutes because he's so
freaking good at working out and heads
back home to eat more cream puffs but
that's when he hears someone inside and
realizes that they're beating up his
sweet old dad this is crazy for them
it's gonna be way fun for us because
look if I was Mash I'm gonna rely my
tight throbbing muscle to beat these
pretty boy Wizards down let me explain
the Dad should have known that Mash
wasn't exactly the brightest pork in the
ramen Bowl since he raised this kid for
like two decades and he should have put
some sort of security measure in place
like I don't know maybe have a second
house that you can hide in or maybe get
a I don't know a better disguise for
Mash like it's not that hard I mean come
on guys not having magic in this world
is a huge deal and pop should have
assumed that one day one day his
teenager would not listen to him he was
so dumb throughout the whole thing and
at this point as Mash we have very few
options if the cops catch us they're
gonna try to kill us that means we need
to think fast now look there's three
viewpoints that I can see when looking
at this house there's the windows and
also the big freaking hole that they
blew in which means I'm gonna take a
sneaky peek and look through these
different Vantage points to see how many
were up against then I'm gonna head back
to my Little Gym pick up a fully loaded
up barbell and come back there and use
that as a weapon because yeah while
we're up against terrifying magic we are
ripped to shreds we just did 10 billion
zerto squats which is like one of the
most badass exercises that you can do in
a Hardcore gym and we're up against
Wizards and usually Wizards are
typically not known for being exactly
the most physically fit which means we
can very easily physically overpower
them waiting outside of the house I'm
gonna first throw a rock into the bushes
to make a noise and get either one or
two of the Wizards to come out then I'm
gonna casually toss one or two of these
45 pound weights right at them because
it's clear that they're part of the DIY
do you even lift club right after I'm
gonna blast through the front door and
simultaneously throw the rest of my
weights and barbell at Blondie over
there disarming him before punching in
his throat and smacking him in the head
while this move may seem simple it's
actually way more advanced because most
people here are Wizards and can do
everything with their magic and just
likely that none of them have ever
learned to handle any sort of physical
trauma but we grew up doing that our
entire life through training back inside
police chief Brad tells the dad that
this world is only meant for pure blood
magic users and anybody who cannot use
magic doesn't deserve to live they don't
have the right and that's when mash
bursts in and beats these cops down in
seconds slapping this one dude in Epic
fashion and it's freaking hilarious and
then he faces off against Brad
channeling his magic and the guy fires
off a beam of lethal energy and his
father yells out in horror as the house
blows up but then the smoke disappears
and everybody stands in shock seeing
Mash completely unharmed Brad then
realizes that this kid pimp slapped his
spell like it was nothing and he quickly
amps up his powers more and fires his
most lethal spell but then Mass just
slaps it away again deflecting the rest
of all of the Spells and then he grabs
his dad's nearby wand and tells his dad
that hey I'm gonna borrow this and Brad
thinks what this guy can use magic after
all because Marshall then proceeds to
launch this wand right at Brad like a
major league baseball player firing it
with blazing speed injuring him and
shocking him and his dad because even
his old bald dad had no idea at Mash's
true Powers he's swole out of moves Brad
gives up but then has an idea and he
offers Mash a new deal to free him and
his dad and tells him that there's an
annual competition starting soon where
the best magic students enroll in magic
school and all will compete for the
grand prize to become the city's new
Divine Visionary if Mash wins the title
it means that God has accepted him and
this means that Society will be forced
to accept him as well however in order
to join he will have to go undercover
but the stakes High Mash accepts the
terrifying deal the next day the city's
most powerful kids show up to the school
Easton magic Academy for the entrance
exam including Mash all the while as his
pops and Brad hide in the back in epic
style because nobody can clearly see
these two adult men hiding in plain
sight they're that good and just then
this famous wizard Claude shows up and
gives them their first test they must
use their magic to stop the letters on
the page from moving and reveal the
questions the terrified students then
get to work image politely tells the
letters to stop moving but nothing
happens and then it gets annoyed and
asks more politely stop moving and it
works the terrified letters freeze into
place allowing him to answer the
questions and somehow he finds out all
sorts of creative muscle-bound ways to
pass the rest of the tests secretly
using his strength and power instead of
magic and fools all of the other kids
and teachers but he's finding that the
tests keep getting harder and harder and
the final test arrives the students are
asked to solve this unsolvable maze in
30 minutes if they don't die inside from
all of the monsters now all alone Mash
accidentally runs into this girl lemon
Irvin scared she asks Mash if she can
tag along with him and it's a little
strange but hey he's jacked so he
accepts going through the maze she
consistently falls into to every single
freaking trap she's pretty pathetic and
mash not caring about her at all tries
to leave but that's when she uses her
magic to turn on him trapping him she
tells him that she was actually sent to
meet him and prevent him from passing
the test but Mash easily breaks out of
her spell with his buff strength
shocking her and says that he must go
leaving her and that's when a huge
magical monster appears in front of
lemon she tries to defend herself but
her wand gets smacked out of her hand
forcing her to stare helplessly and get
ready for her brutal and well-deserved
death but that's when mash suddenly
returns and casually defeats this
monster in one second confused lemon
asks him why he saved her and he tells
her that he felt sorry for her and can
tell that she really is nice deep down
with the timer almost up Mash breaks
through the rest of the maze walls
taking lemon with him and the two
amazingly passed the test shocked at his
methods the rest of the students think
Mash cheated and demanded he gets kicked
out but that's when lemon then reveals
that Professor Claude told her that he'd
fail her if she didn't get in Mash's way
coming from a poor family lemon says she
was forced to make lemonade out of the
deal and accept his offer then this
douchey Professor has then had enough
and gets ready to expel the two but Mash
quickly breaks his wand in a second
terrifying everybody here he's doing
things that should not be possible and
that's when the school's Headmaster
shows up Headmaster Wahlberg and he
tells everyone that he will take over
the rest of the tests from now on and
will conduct personal interviews he then
takes Mash with him up to his office
here the Headmaster then tells Mash that
he doesn't think before he acts and that
one day he will face monsters that are
more powerful than him and to get his
point across the Headmaster uses magic
to create a final test for Mash he tells
him that this doll now has the soul of
his father inside of it and he must try
to save him acting quick Mash tries to
destroy the device with his terrifying
strength but he can't and the Headmaster
knows it he then puts his hands together
under the spike and tries to prevent the
spike from impaling the doll and mash
tells the Headmaster that this is a test
isn't it who can last longer his
strength or the headmaster's magic who
has the better endurance impressed the
Headmaster tells him that magic must be
used to protect the weak and regulate
the strong at least from what he's seen
he thinks Mash is capable of becoming a
great wizard he then asks Mash a final
question of how what would happen if he
actually tried to defeat him an actual
combat and mash tells him honestly that
if they did really fight he would just
kick the living [__] out of him
Headmaster Wahlberg Chuckles and
welcomes him to Easton magic Academy
later he meets up with his new roommate
this kid called Finn Mash introduces
himself and each of his well-developed
muscles and every single one of them
have their own names freaking thin out
and it's here that Mash finds out how to
achieve his goal that will save him and
his dad from certain death in order to
become a Divine Visionary students will
be evaluated on how they perform at
school and based on this they will be
given coins of gold silver or bronze and
they must us gather as many coins as
possible Mash then thanks him and offers
him his most prized possession a cream
puff how nice later all the kids head
into this Hall to find out which of the
three great wizard houses they will be
assigned to by this magical Beast the
house of Adler full of courage and
conviction the house of orca wisdom and
willingness in the house of Lang ability
and ambition and this skeleton horse
thing is able to read minds and put the
right person with the right house but
when it reads Mash's mind it panics
because the only freaking thing that is
in Mash's head right now is glorious
glorious cream puffs and nothing
freaking else getting confused it tries
to explain away why Mash is thinking of
cream puffs and says that he is somebody
that is harboring kindness within
strength and uses this incredible leap
of logic and it assigns him to the Adler
house oh Mash could have had such an
easier time of this but this is really
annoying if I was mashed I would have
prepared way earlier because now
everybody is going to view us as a
punching bag as a servant someone who
can be told what to do and we just will
always say yes that's a problem this is
another example of how Mash's Daddy and
lazy Capo over there didn't really help
Mash at all in any sort of way because
it's clear that none of them ever
bothered to research what type of
activities or events would take place at
the school I mean come on this thing
habits every freaking Year all these
kids are trying to become a Divine
Visionary we couldn't figure out the
school's itinerary that should have been
that hard plus blonde guy being a chief
of police he said oh I don't know maybe
he has some connections that he could
have used to figure some stuff out and
make Master's life easier or trying to I
don't know maybe hide the fact that he
doesn't have magic this comp guy would
have had access to thousands of school
records or files to help Mash better
prepare if I was them I would have
helped Mash prepare and tried to get
into a particular house because well I
don't know maybe house length are known
for winning because if we get into a
house with power like them it's going to
give Mash way more opportunities than if
he tried to do anything himself that's
part of the reason why people go to
expensive schools yes it's expensive but
really at the end of the day it's about
who you know and the connections that
you make oh yes everyone in house Lang
probably is really snooty as all get out
it doesn't matter we can lay low but
eventually we will take over and be
right at the top and all along
everything will be easier for us
sometime later Mash heads to his next
class where the kids can finally learn
how to fly using his two brain cells of
intelligence he knows that he has no
powers but he quickly thinks fast and
pretends to fly on it grabbing his broom
he throws it into the air like a dart
and leaps and catches up with it mid
flight and rides the momentum of it past
the Finish Line acing the test and
keeping his true Secrets safe the
teachers and students get really
impressed everybody except Mash's
roommate Finn who squares he saw
Matthews no magic at all and just then
this school bully Lloyd Cavill
congratulates mash and asks to be his
friend and the other students around him
get nervous not caring or thinking about
anything at all Mash agrees to be his
friend after class he finds out from
Finn that Deloitte is actually a
terrible human being and is the son of a
high-ranking member of the Bureau of
magic and his family is tight with the
school vice principle and if they make
him mad he would be able to get any
student expelled the next day Mass runs
into Lloyd beating Finn up and Finn
tells him to not interfere but Mash his
chiseled self walks up to Lloyd and
smashes his face and tells him to
apologize to his friend now but just
then vice principal farman shows up and
tells Mash that he is in serious trouble
you can't do that so what does MASH do
he kicks this guy's face and breaks his
wand and buries him alive in horror and
he tells the vice principal that he
can't expel him anytime but Mash will
continue to bury him every single time
and nothing will stop it from happening
later he gets called into the
headmaster's office and he tells Mash
that because of what happened the Bureau
of magic wants magic spelled and that
match must take things seriously because
the bureau is the most powerful force in
the country and they are run by Divine
Visionaries and should not be messed
with but the Headmaster then reveals to
mash that he knows Mash used his powers
to help the weak and this is why he
became the Headmaster of this school he
tells him that he hopes Mash can become
a Divine Visionary someday but Mash
tells him that it's but inevitable Mash
then quickly becomes famous for
defeating one of the school bullies and
soon gets asked to represent his house
in a discount quidditch match and the
guy's name who asked him is Tom he's
super intense and really annoying and
even more single-minded than Mash is but
even then Mash agrees to join as long as
Tom will leave him alone the next day
the match begins but Adler house quickly
falls behind the opposing team the Lang
house absolutely beats down on the Adler
house and mash sees Tom get injured on
purpose by one of their douchey
opponents annoyed at the Injustice Mash
gets on the broom and begins flying what
am I looking at everybody sees him
kicking his legs at supersonic speed for
some reason and he hovers in the air
using his superb strength and speed he
throws the game ball through the goal
and uses his terrifyingly strong fingers
to curve the ball and make it return to
him like a boomerang and he does this
again and again and again and again and
again
times in seconds and quickly scores
enough goals winning the match and he
wins his first silver coin and gets put
into the school newspaper not realizing
that now he's being targeted by this guy
later Mash gets approached in class by
this guy named Lance but he notices that
this student is different and he has two
marks on his face he then asks Mash to
play a game with him opening up this
magic bottle he quickly traps his
friends inside and mash gets ready for
combat as Lance teleports them to this
field he tells Mash that in this school
no one can use their magic to harm each
other unless they make it an official
wizard duel by wagering their coins he
knows that Mash wants to become the next
Divine Visionary and says that there can
only be one he offers him a duel the
winner gets the other's coin he also
reveals that he is a double-line magic
user these guys are way more powerful
and rarer than single line users and
they are already considered gods among
men he criticizes mash and tells him
that he's too soft as a person and that
he must be ruthless if he wants to win
Mash wastes no time and tries to catch a
lance off guard but he easily stops him
with a gravity spell pushed into the
ground Mash stabs his arm into the dirt
and pulls out the roots from under lands
setting him off balance Mash finds out
that Lance also wants to become a Divine
Visionary to become powerful enough to
save his sick sister she is sick with a
disease that will soon get rid of her
magical powers and if this happens she
will be forced to be executed he tells
Mash she's sorry for what he's about to
do and tries to throw Mash's trapped
friends off of the cliff but suddenly
Mash starts acting strange and bends
over and he announces that he will now
use his hamstring magic to save his
friends getting into a sprinter's post
he tightens up his thick hammies and
shoots past lands saving his friends and
coming back up from the cliff in an
instant terrifying Lance to his core he
thinks Mash must be using some type of
physical enhancement magic and he has no
idea that Mash is basically the physical
embodiment of one punch man in this
universe smash tells him that he doesn't
think Lance is a bad guy and wants to be
friends stunned at his kindness Lance
anime changes his mind and offers Mash
one of his silver coins as a sign of
French a few days later Mash's wizard
house gets set to face off against house
Lang again in a challenge more
horrifying than the last third task
exterminate these Forest scorpions and
retrieve the silver or bronze stones on
their forehead whoever gets the most
will get an additional silver coin
Mash's group gets ready for a
bloodthirsty battle but then this new
kid bumps into mash and sucker punches
him to the floor he tries to go after
him again but Lance stops IT and tells
him that the kid is named Silva and
unlike the other bullies he's a legit
psycho he's killed students and even
teaches before but he's never been
expelled because of his talent
apparently and that boys will be boys so
weird the group then decides to split
into groups Lance and mash will head
into the dark Forest together but Mash
accidentally zones odd for one second
and ends up getting lost with any bumps
into this red-haired kid named Dot and
suddenly they hear a horrifying scream
nearby and find helpless girl about to
get killed by this student they decide
to go rescue her and that is their
biggest mistake dot quickly takes this
kid out and this girl quickly Falls for
him instantly this seems a little
suspicious not a ladies man at all dot
quickly falls in love with her in
seconds not realizing that she is
actually using a love spell on him with
DOT under her spell this girl then tries
to secretly use her powers on Mash but
she realizes that he doesn't really have
a brain for her to take control of and
means that her powers are useless
against him realizing that she can't
beat him she comes clean and tells them
that a kid named Silva actually
threatened her unless she tried to stop
house Adler during this competition but
that's when Silva suddenly shows up and
Dot here fouls to become the white
knight in shining armor that he knows he
can be and finally he will be a true
ladies man he threatens Silva and shoots
his magic spell at him and the girl in
Mash watch while eating cream puffs but
that's when dot begins to realize that
he's just made a terrible mistake
sensing that Silva's powers are on a
whole other level he could gets injured
badly he's so stupid this dot look if I
was him I would win this match by
playing Dirty by becoming this psycho
overpowered Wizard's little servant let
me explain dot here is a first year
student off-duty Sim hardcore and has
magic that involves trading exploding
Fireballs very useful but here's a
problem he's up against resident psycho
Silva who is a second year student and
whose magic allows him to control masses
of iron but here's the thing Dodd only
uses most obvious spells machine gun
explosion against him and on top of that
he already knew that Silva was a double
line magic user which means that it
should have been obvious that the only
way to take this guy down was by doing a
surprise attack don't attack him front
on look there is a slight delay between
the moment a magic user draws their wand
and the moment they aim and cast their
spell the amount of time it takes for
this to happen is maybe one to two
seconds Max that is useful if we try to
draw Silva in closer but we could be
within Striking Distance we would be
able to disarm his wants and or disarm
his face with our fist fight dirty it
works getting bored Silva proposes A new
challenge to both Mash and Dot they must
endure five hits from each of his magic
and if they can survive he'll leave this
girl alone and he will even bet one
silver coin dot agrees but offers to
take on Mash's hits too since he is the
one who got them into this silver smiles
he shoot a new spell at Dot and he takes
it and he trembles and he coughs up
blood hit after hit dot takes them off
and Still Remains standing impressed
silver offers him one last hit but this
time makes the attack twice as deadly
and this time it works dot now collapses
to the floor and he yells at mash and
the girl to run but that's when he finds
out that this sweet girl is actually
working with Silva she goes to him and
tells dot that she hates white Knights
like him and Dot realizes that he
sacrificed himself for nothing Silva
laughs as he tries to kill dot for real
but that's when mash finally intercepts
the magic and switches to triceps magic
and ballista knuckle magic and he shoots
right at Silva destroying his attacks
and blowing him back making this bully
cough up blood and that's when a huge
scorpion also shows up with a huge
star-shaped Stone on its forehead gets
ready to unleash its Horrors onto the
group but Mash tells him that hey I'm
busy and pimp slaps him into the
stratosphere and the Stone from his
forehead lands on the floor seeing Silva
badly injured Mash offers a truce since
he feels was bad for him out of options
this girl also gives up and starts
crying and mash comes over to hug her
and she thinks that haha he's finally
falling for her charms but that's when
he breaks her back and says that he
believes in treating everybody equally
when it comes to ass kicking after the
competition Mash meets back up with his
group Lance Finn and lemon and they find
out that he beat Silva and the Scorpion
earning him two silver coins dot then
comes over and thanks him for teaming up
Lance then interrupts them with some
horrifying news he's overheard in the
school that their house Adler is being
targeted by their Rivals the house of
Lang and they've begun hunting for coins
and have started to Target their house
and this is likely why Silva picked a
fight with mash in the first place Lance
warns them that Lang house is made up of
snooty Rich Elite folks who value
Birthright and bloodline over anything
else and will do anything to prevent
nobodies like them from becoming Divine
Visionaries and getting into the Bureau
of magic a war has now started for coins
against house Lang's Elite known as the
Magna lupus consisting of a group of
seven students suddenly matches five
silver coins to begin to merge and
become one gold coin making mash now one
of their most valuable people in the
whole school Lance tells him because of
this he should stay away from their
rival house as often as he can and
should it roam the hallways alone
anymore but later what does he do Mash
totally forgets what Lance said and
somehow ends up lost in the school
meanwhile in the headquarters of magnium
Lupus the leader of the group Abel here
gives some [__] to Silver for losing to
house and turns him into a horrifying
doll as punishment Abel then puts Silva
on his wall full of dolls and announces
that this year's Divine Visionaries must
be from their house only suddenly the
loudest Door Creek is heard and
everybody here turns to see MASH enter
unaware that he just entered the house
of his worst enemy Abel smiles and says
he knows who Mash is and tells him that
he's too weak to become a Divine
Visionary because he cares too much for
people their kind must be ruthless and
aspire to rule the world fully because
Society has become weak enable is about
to Rattle on but then he can tell that
Mash is completely lost so he gives up
and tells him to go only if he hands
over his valuable gold coin but Mash
refuses this anchors Abel and
immediately sends over his puppet to
attack him grabbing Mash's coin and
gives it back to Abel but Mash hits the
puppet down and sees it turned back into
Silva seeing him injured Mash tells Abel
that he must go to help Silva instead
and these two quickly leave the
headquarters and Abel lets them go he's
got the coin that he wanted anyways but
then he realizes that he's not holding
on to a coin but a button and he
realizes that he's somehow been tricked
and this pink hair girl realizes what
she really saw later Silva wakes up and
sees Mash working out and developing his
abs and realizes that he saved him and
he ends up liking mash and decides not
to be a douchebag anymore going to show
you that muscles do change a person Mash
then heads back to his dorm there he
whips out a cream puff while Lance then
reveals to them a crazy plan to beat
their rival house he says that house
Lang has most of the gold coins while
their house only has one gold coin and
he said that while they only have one
that belongs to Mash House Lang has way
more and he's found out that since this
started this year house Lang has started
stealing all of the other House's coins
illegal and at this rate they will win
the competition all of the Adler Wizards
strong enough to put a stop to this are
away on off-campus internships and Orca
House are a bunch of nerds that just
study and don't really care about the
competition and this means that it's up
to these guys to stop the evil wizard
house but last minute Mash finds out
that the Headmaster was forced to give
him some punishment for beating up that
vice principal earlier and his
punishment is that he has to clean this
owl Nest first and oh my gosh they're so
cute Lance catches up with him and
updates him on their plan to win the
competition he says that he's just found
out that men from house Lang will likely
try to take Mash's gold coin soon that's
why he's here to protect him because
shit's about to go down but suddenly
Mash disappears into a magic puddle of
water and these flesh-eating shuriken
dashes past Lance's face almost killing
him man actually yells that he can't
swim and struggles for his life as these
two house Lang members enter sixth Fang
olore Andrew and seventh Fang and Sir
shinry pissed off they say they're here
for blood and offered these two an
official duel for their gold coins sixth
Fang then turns into this horrifying
shark human hybrid and jumps into the
magical water to kill Mash leaving Lance
to face off against seventh Fang about
to use his gravity magic Lance realizes
that he can't otherwise he'll kill all
of the cute owls and he can't do that
because his sister loves owls oh that's
annoying so he takes a brutal beating
instead while he lures these cute fluffy
little turd blossoms away from the
Killzone and he waits for his opening to
strike alright now things are getting a
little bit more serious rub against one
of the most deadly Wizards here in terms
of students if I was Lance I would kill
this wizard by killing these cute
animals here and by rupturing this guy's
orbital Globe let me explain it's noted
that all the Wizards here on average
have at least one special ability which
they use repeatedly makes them very
predictable it's so stupid and this
includes also these two baddies while my
somehow will come out on top this means
that while we're up against someone who
is strong they seem to rely on only
predictable ranged magic through this
only one source this shuriken this guy
however has the power to control
freaking gravity that's amazing which
means our attacks can go on a wide scale
but right now we're surrounded by these
cute little fluffy creatures they're
adorable and also smelly probably
because we're surrounded by bird poop
like all wizards if you have the power
to move the TV remote closer to you
without moving you would and this means
that Wizards are likely lazy and likely
in no way would they expect up close and
personal encounters once we get to close
range I would take my wand and shove it
right up this guy's nose lodging it
directly to where the nasal cartilage is
I would then violently rip it towards us
and upward instantly Breaking part of
the nasal cavity which would really make
it hard for this guy to breathe
instantly making him blind and also
ruined whatever potential future this
kid had in his life once the baby owls
are finally clear Lance activates his
magic and kicks this guy's ass meanwhile
deep in the magical sea field sixth Fang
announces that Mash is dead but that's
when he sees something shoot past him
with terrifying speed he realizes it's
mash and mash stops and tells him that
he just learned how to swim in the past
five minutes and thanks him for helping
him panicking shark man turns into sea
Shark Evolution and lunges at Mash to
bite his head off but he easily gets
destroyed by Mash's sick breaststroke
beating this Baddie in five anime
minutes the house Adler ends up winning
the duel and collects their second gold
coin they think hey it's over and they
get ready to head home but that was
their biggest mistake the barn doors
then blast open and this mysterious
masked man appears saying he's only here
to retrieve his team members from House
land wasting no time Lance tries to
attack this guy but he easily Dodges his
attack like it's nothing Mash has a turn
but easily gets dodged and he just did
something that no other wizard against
Mash has ever done before the masked man
then reveals that while he's here to
rescue his teammates he also wanted to
get a glimpse of their powers and thanks
them and he tells them that he'll be
meeting them again soon and he
disappears and leaves these two more
nervous than ever later Lance comes up
with a plan to beat house Lang the
school hides the living areas of each of
the houses in order to keep all of this
students save but if they can figure out
where house Lang is they can try to
steal their coins and all the while Mash
is pounding down some tasty tasty cream
puffs he hands smash a sick Adler house
rope and then they find out that their
friend Tom has just been admitted to the
doctor he tells them the strangest thing
has happened last night he had a dream
he was trapped in a box and when he woke
up he couldn't use magic anymore and
he's not the only one the doctors do not
know what's wrong other students are
also suffering the same fate lemon then
realizes that all of this happened when
the Headmaster had to travel to the
Bureau of magic leaving the school
vulnerable with no time to lose they
agree to meet back up that same night to
begin looking for house lying but then
they noticed that lemon hasn't shown up
agreeing to go on without her they
suddenly notice who they think is lemon
walking around these empty halls but
something is wrong and then she turns
around but sees no one because all of
them are hiding behind this corner
realizing that someone has put a
terrifying spell on her they secretly
follow her down this corner and she
disappears sensing a secret door on the
floor Mash breaks through it using
simple physics and extreme strength and
they head down below following this
light down the hall they enter into an
ancient wizard Arena suddenly this
red-haired kid bodyguard appears and
tells them third Fang sent him to kill
any Intruders that try and enter and
he's not part of their group knowing
he's about to throw down he challenges
them to a death match using their gold
coins and Dot then steps up and offers
to take one for the team again meanwhile
the Headmaster now at the Bureau of
magic gets told why he's been called six
of death Rose's most notorious inmates
have escaped from heka trees and they
were assisted by innocent zero meaning
No One Is Safe including all of the
students back of the school back at the
school dot tries to fight this kid but
quickly realizes that he is no match
because this wizard can't be killed and
just then the floor breaks apart and
everybody falls down getting separated
this glasses guy shows up in front of
Lance and the rest and they're forced to
face off against the first year
double-line students and Lance faces off
against the third Fang meanwhile Mash
goes off to try and find his friends but
runs into the same masked wizard from
earlier and he introduces himself off as
magia lupus Abyss razor and tells Mash
that he's in trouble because he knows
about his deepest secret Mash doesn't
have any powers and he knows it Mash
tries to play it off but Abyss tells him
that he's just like him someone hated by
this world and he takes out his sword
and forces Mash to prepare for a death
match back in the other Arena where at
the duels with Lance and is impressed
with his powers and he offers him a
chance to join house lag and tells him
that in order to excel in life he must
surround himself with powerful people in
order to not end up like his loser
friends but Lance refuses hissing
weareth off he then takes out a
concentrated magical Essence from his
pockets and is told that this potion is
made from the powers of other students
that only his house has access to
drinking it he gets roided up and his
powers augment causing a more powerful
spell and a terrifying monster manifest
right in front of him and whereth
reveals that second death magic is
different than single line magic users
and only double line magic users can use
this kind of magic knowing he won't
survive Lance reveals that he also has
access to second death Magic and whips
out his upgraded Spell creating these
pillars in front of the monster giving
off a strong gravitational pull towards
them the poles quickly ripped the
monster apart in all directions
destroying this guy's ego in exactly 10
seconds it's off after Lance feels bad
for him and tells him that he respects
the effort he put into his magic and
leaves him back at Mash they wait for
him to change into his fighting costume
and Mash Attacks Abyss but finds out
that this wizard can use a new type of
magic and easily overpowers Mash Abyss
tells him that Mash is similar to him
and reveals that he's holding lemon
hostage in 30 minutes this device will
drain lemon of her powers unless they
can stop him Mash tries to beat him but
gets beaten to Hell Abyss continues to
use his Force Arrow magic and cuts him a
thousand times in seconds and stabs Mash
in the stomach but that's when mash
thinks fast and flexes his muscles
trapping the sword within and head butts
Abyss destroying his mask and that's
when he sees his red eye and he doesn't
know what it means ashamed Abyss reveals
that he has the evil eye of the devil
and anybody who looks at it gets their
magic powers temporarily disabled
because of his powers growing up nobody
ever wanted to be his friend and his
parents tried to kill Abyss then
unleashes accelerated second death and
creates this magic force field around
them trapping Mash in place as Abyss
quickly gives him more cuts and he tells
Mash that this force field decreases the
speed of everyone else in it and grants
the speed to him and he gets ready to
deliver the final lethal attack to mash
but Mash at the last minute smashes the
floor forcing him best to come closer to
attack him as Mash traps his foot and he
deploys full muscles magic hurricane
Rush that sounds epic and smashes Abyss
through the roof and he activates the
rest of his magical muscles forearm
quadriceps pectorals iliosos and then he
uses his girtheor Rector spinae to
finish the job defeated Abyss gets sad
and tells him that he should never have
been born but the leader of Magna lupus
Abel needed him and now no one needs him
anymore feeling bad Mash offers him
friendship Abyss thanks him and tells
him that if he goes down any further
Abel will kill him but Mash says he must
because that Abel needs a good ass
kicking and he bids Abyss farewell and
tells him that they they should eat
cream puffs together next time nearby
Finn and Dot get ready to take on these
lupus baddies love cute and fourth Fang
Milo genius but Milo here then leaves
these two for love to handle but this
girl is a rather super weirdo and
suddenly asks them if they think she's
cute confused Finn tells her to chill
out since they just met but dot
confesses to Finn that he kind of likes
her weirdness however he says that since
he's already has a fiance who he also
barely knows and he remains loyal to her
and this makes love Angry and she gets
ready to kill these two right here okay
this is crazy because we're up against a
certified freak though and maybe I let
her step on us in order to survive let
me explain love cute here is one of the
most powerful Wizards and part of the
best house in this school and she's a
total nutcase and basically she can
create a magical tornado so that's a
problem however it's obvious that
everybody here is trying to become a
Divine Visionary and that's why if I was
them I would have tried to study up on
all of the double line users because
that makes sense because there's not
many of them they're super rare they're
a statistical Rarity which means it's
not that hard to memorize who they are
what their powers are impossibly what
are their weaknesses this girl wanted us
to like her so freaking bad and that
means if she wants our approval she
might have to go through some hoops in
order to get it we could manipulate her
which probably won't even be that hard
and I'll tell her the only way for us to
be together and for her to love us would
be for her to impress us by providing us
with favors not that kind of favor like
stepping on us lady Demetrius Goose
style and telling us we're worthless we
just lie down in the fetal position the
moment she walks over and gets real
close to us we're gonna do a leg sweep
knock her down to the ground and Bob her
in the head a few times to knock her out
and call it a day love shoots a
devastating spell at them and Dot
quickly counters with an exploding spell
love angrila yells that girls are
princesses and everybody must live to
serve and love them dot tries to reach
for her wand but she sees him coming and
beats his face telling them that Milo's
Powers allow him to turn a specified
Target into stone it means that any
person who opened the Secret Door into
this floor will soon turn into stone
Mash horrified she tells them they have
30 minutes to save Mash she creates a
new spell and traps dot inside about to
die dot loses Consciousness and this
causes him to turn into this new Wizard
creature surprised love tries to kill
him but realizes that his power level
has now doubled and notices what's on
his forehead named the warding cross she
realizes that dot is a part of a rare
group of wizard known as battled demons
who unleash their magic power when their
emotions cross a certain threshold dot
fires off machine gun magic at love but
misses her on purpose telling her that
he doesn't like to hit girls that she
should leave now scared at his new
powers she thanks him and just then this
Stone monster appears from nowhere and
tries to eat thin dot thinks fast and
quickly protects it but gets badly
injured just as Milo comes back Milo
gets ready to kill them but then gets
stabbed by something and that's when a
Divine Visionary shows up named Rey Ames
Rey easily defeats Milo and beats the
[__] out of him telling Finn and Dot to
leave and Dot finds out that this guy is
Finn's older brother getting valuable
information out of Milo Rey then leaves
and heads to find out who he's really
looking for innocent zero who he knows
is hiding out in this school and is in
Disguise he comes across Mash eating a
cream puff but doesn't know who he is
and can sense his immense power levels
suspicious he takes out this magic
spider that can detect power levels but
it tells Rey that this kid has no magic
powers at all strange but then he finds
out from Ash's name that the Headmaster
did mention Mash to him and his
potential Rey apologizes and hands him a
magic handkerchief as a gift and tells
him that this thing can heal wounds he
tells Mash that he will soon meet his
most horrifying opponent yet and that
the top candidate to be the next Divine
Visionary Abel Rey tells him that if he
can beat him he can inherit all of
Abel's gold coins and he's got a whole
lot of them having more important things
to do he wishes Mash good luck and they
part ways Mash continues to explore
these dark hallways and discovers this
door opening it he sees Abel inside Abel
spots him and tells him that he
surprised Mash survived against Rey
gaining respect for Mash he tells him
that the world cannot be fair and the
week like those who cannot use magic
must be exterminated Mash is shocked and
tells him that because Abel is so
freaking mean they probably can't be
friends and that's when Abel orders his
magic puppets to attack Mash but that's
when love passes by outside and sees
what's going on defeating this puppet
Mash is shocked to find his friend Finn
approaching him as a puppet Abel tells
Mash that if he tries anything he will
break Finn apart unable to harm Finn
Mash takes out his gold coin and flicks
it at Finn's puppet strings cutting them
and setting him free this pisses Abel
off and he traps Mash in puppet strings
as well but Mash goes into runner's
stance and fires off his developed
glutes heading straight for Abel and
breaks his face in Abel panics and uses
a deadly spell Marion s change instantly
turning Mash into a doll now under his
spell Abel smiles and approaches him he
tries to take out Mash's gold coin but
that's when he accidentally takes out a
cream puff instead and that was his
biggest Miss causing a knee-jerk
reaction and mash and he sticks out his
hand to grab the cream puff and
partially changes back into a human Abel
is shocked and says this is impossible
since his puppet magic blocks signals to
the brain but Mash reveals that touching
his most precious item in his jacket the
cream puff must have sent a spinal
reflex through his body that overrided
his brain Abel suspects that this means
hanging onto his cream puff must have
been that important to him both amazed
and pissed off Abel reveals that he's
collected enough magic in this machine
from other Wizards and other students
and now plans to channel it into his
most terrifying Spell Aryan s second
death using all of their powers he
creates this giant puppet monster that
can turn anything within its radius into
puppets the moments its magical strength
touches anyone this monster attacks Mash
but easily breaks its arms off shocking
able Mash tells him that in slow motion
he managed to tear off the strings of
the puppet by bending his body in a
certain way in order to delay contact
with the rest of the strings once he put
the string on his left side before he
lost control of his right side he
snapped that string before the others
could reach him able then gives up and
says that Mash May makes no sense at
this point and he shoots Mash but Mash
blocks him and sneaks up from behind
activating his muscles magic erector
spinae magic hellfall and he slams Abel
into the floor and swiftly defeats him
now sad and somehow Not Dead from that
ordeal Abel tells him that his mother
was a kind woman to everybody but was
killed by a peasant years ago and this
is why he hates the weak and the poor
Mash forces him to release lemon and
everyone else that he has under his
control and the rest of Mash's teammates
show up and cheer Mash on and everybody
gets happy but then lemon asks where is
Lance elsewhere a continues his search
down this hallway when he runs into
Lance but something is different he can
tell this guy doesn't belong in this
school and shoots a spell right at it
but gets deflected Lance then transforms
into the infamous innocent zero and
congratulates Rey for figuring him out
and reveals that his dark magic
organization Works within the shadows of
this school and Society Rey asks him
what is he doing here but innocent zero
tells him that him and his evil team
forced Abel to search for something
really important to them but he couldn't
find it because of this he's come back
to this school to kill Abel for being so
freaking useless Rey asks him what is he
looking for by innocent zero just tells
him that he doesn't have time to fight
and calls upon his henchmen and serial
killer to fight Rey in a death match
meanwhile in the main room Ash and his
friends celebrate everything going back
to normal and mash goes to the bathroom
but just then innocent zero enters the
room knocking Master's friends back and
approaches Abel ready to kill him he
thanks him for giving him information
about the headmaster's whereabouts and
tells him that his service is no longer
needed using his powerful magic he
forces Abel to choke himself and tells
him that he failed in finding one of the
most powerful Wizards he was searching
for Mash then suddenly enters back with
a big old plate of cream puffs that
stares at the room or confused a fly
sits on his nose causing him to sneeze
and blow all of his cream puffs all over
the place innocent zero has no time for
this and tries to kill him but that's
when he suddenly has a light headache
and suspects Mash has something to do
with it sensing his powers he wonders if
Mash was the one they're looking for
this whole time he tells Mash he'll kill
him in just a sec and turns around to
finish off murdering Abel but best
quickly appears and blocks Abel from the
lethal spell losing blood quickly Abyss
apologizes to mash that he won't be able
to eat cream puffs with him and mash
walks up to him and hands him this
magical handkerchief and tells him to
wipe himself with it as it will heal him
innocent zero stands confused and
realizes that in a split second Mash
threw a pebble at his head when he fired
his spell and this caused his attack to
not be fatal realizing his true
potential innocent zero finally
understands that Mash isn't as weak as
he looks and mash gets mad at the guy
for harming his friends and power Stomps
on the floor kicking one of the flying
rocks right at innocent zero but he
catches it and licks it like a freak he
tells Mash that Abyss only has minutes
until he dies from blood loss and tells
Mash that he needs to hurry up and
defeat him so he can save his friends he
fires devastating spells and mash
forcing him to block at lightning speed
but it's no use and he quickly gets
injured Abel watches and knows that this
is one battle that Mash cannot win he
calls Abyss a fool for trying to save
him but Mash tells him that Abyss was
alone all his life and he was happy when
Abel needed him and blah blah blah a
bunch of anime friendship type crap
let's get back to the good stuff Eva
thinks of what to do as Mash does his
best to defend him and his friends
against innocent Zero running out of
power and strength everybody watches his
end to come closer knowing what he must
do Abel creates a giant puppet spell
around them and makes it attack innocent
zero but it quickly gets blown to pieces
and just then mash comes out of this
puppet head surprising innocent zero and
beating his face and breaking the armor
around his body and he is impressed by
Mash's powers and asks him what his
personal magic is but Mash doesn't know
what to say and innocent zero thinks
Mash won't tell him and whips out his
spell flexion mirror telling him that
this thing reflects spells back to the
magic user but
Mash Just face Stomps him breaking the
mirror and his face is awesome and
everybody finally realizes that he
doesn't have magic powers at all
breaking through this reality this giant
hand comes in to take innocent zero away
and reveals his real name is cell War
how original and he'll be seeing Mash
again very soon and he disappears saving
the day Abel takes Abyss to the dock and
thanks Mash Mash's friends agree to keep
himmash's secret a secret but that's
when this random student wakes up nearby
and overhears everything and he yells at
he'll report him and exposed them all
that Mash has the Panic munchies and
proceeds to Chow Down on a protein cream
puff to chill out fueling his magic
muscles and thinking about his next
glorious workout set but what did you
think about the video what would you do
different don't forget to like subscribe
and leave a comment down below and as
always don't forget to check out our how
to be playlist